welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 16 and
we're gonna learn how you can set
goals and follow through like a
billionaire
[Music]
enjoy
[Music]
you first have to say what what is the
goal
and once you have what is the goal you
can then measure the various designs
against that goal
um if otherwise you're saying how are
you evaluating why is one design better
than another what's your goal
it's gotta be a goal natural human
tendency is wishful thinking
um so a challenge for entrepreneurs is
to say well what's the difference
between
really believing in your ideals and
sticking to sticking to them
versus pursuing some unrealistic dream
that
doesn't actually have merit and it's
it's that is a that is a really
difficult
thing to to tell you can you tell the
difference between those two things
right now so you need to be sort of
very rigorous um in your self self
analysis
um i think certainly extremely tenacious
uh and um and then just
work like hell i mean you just have to
put in
you know 80 hour 80 to 100 hour weeks
every week
and then a lot of work that but all
those things improve the odds of success
okay um i mean if if other people are
putting in 40 hour work weeks and you're
putting in
100 hour work weeks then even if
uh you're doing the same thing you know
that in
in one year you will achieve what they
achieve you you will achieve
in four months what it takes them a year
to achieve
we're focused on like said it is
important to have that that have the
objective you're right
as far as talking so much about the
importance of
making well mars a self-sustaining as
building a self-sustaining city on mars
if that's the objective then obviously
you know just putting some satellites a
little bit or
there's not that that's not important
you have to achieve full and rapid
reusability
amp size full and rapid reusability is
only relevant to the degree that's rapid
and complete
and and then you also have to do orbital
refilling this is essential
as well um and uh and then
um propellant production on mars also
essential
so uh you know
and with that as the goal then
you know that that means that that that
creates i think a good forcing function
for
radical innovation because in the
absence of radical innovation we have no
chance of meeting that goal
um whereas if i go simply
you know defeat lockheed and boeing or
something like that
that that we would probably achieve i've
already done it
it that really wasn't even a thing you
know i wish it was
um yeah like they're not really trying
to do
they're not even trying to do
reusability which is bizarre because
they make planes that are reusable
um so i mean if they if they talk to
like you know if they talk to one of
their customers about bias or
a lockheed fighter jet or a boeing
aircraft like hey we're going to sell
you a
737 it can be used once and it's not 737
max
turns out that was a single use airplane
at times um
but it really uh
it would be an absurd thing for them to
sell a
single use aircraft but they feel quite
comfortable selling a single-use rocket
um and anyway but if our goal is simply
we're going to have to be the leaders in
launching the conventional satellites
that exist
we would probably approach that in on a
sort of a logarithmic basis
where you know you get there and you
sort of slowly make progress towards
doing
10 launches a year 12 launches a year
and while they do six or something like
that know
um but since the goal is
hey we need to make life multi-planetary
before it's too late um
and time really matters so we're
our states also it's like we're shooting
for mars not just the moon
it's not much suit for the moon shoot
for mars um and then and then the
you know these these competitive things
are are kind of small
things along the way unless somebody
else is shooting for mars they will not
be competitive
with something as a pedestrian
is launching a few satellites into earth
orbit if you write your goals down it
makes all the difference harvard did a
study
in 1973 they
took the graduating class and asked how
many of them had goals 100 of them had
goals well they asked how many had
written down their goals upon graduation
only five percent of the class had in
1993 20 years later they followed up
with the class
they found that the five percent that
had written down their goals 20 years
prior upon
graduating were worth more financially
than the other 95 percent of the class
put together
so i have always written my goals down
about what i wanted to achieve and i
really attribute a lot to that
everything i've ever done has started
small amazon started with
a couple of people and
blue origin started with five
people and the budget at blue origin was
very very small now the budget of blue
origins
approaches a billion dollars a year and
next year it'll be more than a billion
dollars
in amazon it literally was 10 people
today it's half a million people but
you it's hard to remember for you guys
but for me it's like yesterday i was
driving the
packages to the post office myself and
hoping one day we could afford a
forklift and so
so for me i've seen small things get big
and it's part of this day one mentality
i like treating things as if if they're
small you know
amazon even though it is a large company
i wanted to have the heart and spirit of
a small one
most of the work that we put into um
any particular quarter happened years
ago so it's not you know there's there
aren't that many knobs you can turn
during a quarter i mean you can but
they're very they're like eating your
seed corn
if you turn those knobs you don't want
to do that and so
uh it's it's uh i
you know people i think if you focus on
the controllable inputs to your business
instead of the outputs
in the long term you get better results
so the
the benjamin graham quote here is that
in the short term the
stock market is a voting machine in the
long term it's a weighing machine
and i think people are well advised to
build a company that wants to be weighed
and not voted upon
and that means having good return on
invested capital and having
you know lots of free cash flow but if
you said to me if i said
here's a job i would reject if somebody
came to me and said jeff i want your job
to be to drive up the amazon stock price
and just manage that directly now this
might sound ridiculous to some of you
but many companies actually do this they
have
they actually go out and they try to
sell the stock that's kind of the final
output and it's much better to say
okay let's not do that that's not going
to be sustainable it's kind of a silly
approach
um what are the inputs to a higher
stock price and it's okay well free cash
flow and
return on invested capital inputs to a
higher stock price okay
so let's let's keep working backwards
what are the inputs to
free cash flow and you keep working
backwards until you get to something
that's controllable
and a controllable input for free cash
flow would be something like lower cost
structure
and you back up from there and you say
okay well you know if we can improve our
picking efficiency and our fulfillment
centers and reduce defects
defects are very very costly it's prob
you know reducing defects at the root is
one of the best ways to lower cost
structure
and so if you then that starts to be a
job you would accept
you would say if you're you know a
reasonable person you would say i have
no idea how to
uh drive up the stock price i can't
manage that directly it's not a
controllable input
but i i can make your picking algorithms
more efficient
and that will reduce cost structure and
then you know
follow that chain all along the way
that's what you do
in all of these businesses the one thing
i i'm not smarter than anybody else but
i can outwork you
and my key to success for
you or anybody else is make sure you're
the first one in there every day and the
last one to leave
don't ever take a lunch break or go to
the bathroom you keep working
you never know when that opportunity is
going to come along and at solomon
brothers
the managing partner of the company bill
solomon was the
second person in i was the only other
one in the big trading room
so if he had needed to borrow a match in
those days people smoked cigars
and if he wanted to ask something about
a newspaper or a stock
he came over and so we became buddies i
would never have
gotten to talk to the managing partner
of a big company
on a first name basis if it wasn't for
the fact that the two of us are there
billy i'm getting coffee would you like
some
uh and i can bring you that and at the
end of the day the number two guy john
good friend he was the last one to leave
except for me and we'd share a cab going
uptown or take the subway train going
uptown together
and you know every opportunity ever had
it was
i think a lot a lot of them was because
i was there at the time
and that's the one thing you can control
you can you can't control your luck but
the harder you work the luckier you get
you can't control that you're the
smartest guy they'll always be somebody
smarter
but if you're there then you
absorb things you put things together in
a ways that if you didn't have all that
experience
it's like skiing i've said reading a
book on skiing
doesn't teach you how to ski you got to
go and you got to
ski and get lots of miles under your
skis
and incidentally if you don't fall
you're not skiing hard enough and you're
not learning anything so
if your career has ups and downs i got
fired didn't turn out so bad
but you know you can start a little
business and maybe it doesn't work and
after a while you've got to say be smart
to say hey i tried it
don't let your ego get in the way i
can't keep doing this i've got to earn a
living
but you know a year from now i'm going
to come up with a better idea and then
i'll go back and do it again
and have that drive to look at the
bright side and i've
with the exception of um i've always
i've never it's never been a day that i
haven't looked forward to going into
work even the days i knew i was going to
get beaten up even the day i knew i was
going to get fired
i'd never been fired before i wonder
what it's like okay let's go find out
yeah and i've never looked back i i i
find it fascinating people spend and
we're doing this in this country
we're spending all our time trying to
blame people and figure out why we got
to where we are now
rather than focusing on how you get out
of where we are now and make it better
and successful people look to the future
and unsuccessful people look to the back
there's no doubt
that the anti-trust lawsuit was bad for
microsoft
and if we would have been more focused
on
creating the uh phone operating system
and so instead of using
android today you would be using windows
mobile
if it hadn't been for the honor trust
case uh microsoft would go oh we were so
close
we we you know i was just too distracted
i screwed that up
uh because of the distraction and you
know we were just three months too late
with the release that motorola would
have used on a phone
uh so yes uh it's a winner take all game
that
is for sure that you know now nobody
here's ever heard of windows mobile
uh but oh well and i wouldn't
uh well that's a few hundred billion
here or there
uh i wouldn't have retired
as soon and that one is less you know i
am disappointed that windows mobile
didn't succeed but in terms of
uh my own life you know even though it
was a very painful thing
because i got very personally involved
in the defense of the company
the fact that i retired earlier probably
net was good for me because i got
down the learning curve on the
foundation i got to partner with melinda
in the early days of the foundation
and you know i don't have a life where
i'm allowed to complain
uh because basically you know only 99
of things have worked out very very well
typically entrepreneurs
they create a financial plan when
they're young
that's the best financial plan they can
get venture capital investors or angel
investors to believe
thinking that'll maximize valuation and
maximize the chances of raising money
the problem is this is more than just a
like one and done in terms of raising
money you have to raise money multiple
times
most likely and so my advice would be
put together a financial plan that's
the worst plan you can get
and raise money on and they're very
different sometimes
because once you raise money on a plan
that you know you can crush
you build momentum and it's that
momentum that's going to carry you
from round to round because there's
definitely
um the investment community is a lot
smaller than people think
and word spreads quickly if you're
crushing plan
you're going to get people's attention
if you're not hitting plan it's going to
be tough
everything you try to do is already done
so when i figured that out oh what i'm
putting
out is what's coming back let me get
real clear
about what it is i'm putting out real
clear
so i read a book about 1989 called seed
of the soul
and in that book gary zukov talked about
the laws
of karma of the laws
of cause and effect the third law of
motion
and in that book he talked about how
intention your intention is
always one
with the law meaning before you even
think about a thing
you have an intention for the thing and
that the
intention is going to determine the
outcome
that's why the same people can go to the
same church service
and somebody walked down the aisle just
to be seen
to put some money in the
church and somebody else who just goes
and just has a little bit to offer
the intention with which you give
the intention with which you serve
determines the outcome so when i figured
that out
i went whoa i changed
everything i did on my show i called in
the producers and i said
from this day forward i will no longer
be speaking to the kkk
will no longer be speaking to people
who are fighting each other in a way
that it is damaging to the character of
myself and other people who watch
from this day forward i am only going to
do
intentional television if you don't want
to give up
everything you will get nothing
a lot of business people they never
learn to focus
if your startup learn to be focused on
one thing
right because learn to be focused just
like there are nine rabbits on the
ground
if you want to catch the rabbit don't
change the rabbit
change yourself if you want to catch
this one get finally get nothing so for
nine rabbits
don't change the rabbit change yourself
to catch that rabbit until you got it
can you help us understand how to
cultivate how to cultivate
that mindset of being comfortable saying
no being comfortable delegating this is
something that
we found with our members is especially
difficult for young women
it's tough um and we'd love to just hear
your take on that and maybe any advice
you have to share about that
i met bill gates bill gates in 1991
and when i did it we had a great time
talking he thought he was going to hate
it and i
i wasn't too keen on it either and about
10 hours later we were still talking but
what really got him is when i pulled out
this little date book
i'm probably the only guy in the united
states with one of these still what the
oh no i have one over there
and i just flipped through it and you
know there's there's practically nothing
in it and bill was really impressed by
that and uh
you've got to keep control of your time
and and you won't keep control of your
time unless you can say no
uh you you can't let other people
set your agenda in life and of course i
know i'm in a very fortunate position on
that because i can
i and in another way i'm not so
fortunate because more people ask me for
things
and and and they're and they're usually
friends and they say well
can't you just make this one talk or
attend this one graduation or whatever
it may be
uh you know you've got to you just have
to develop the ability to say no and
and and uh do it a few times uh i mean
you know if a woman can't say no she's
in trouble right
right and i mean is this something that
becomes easier over time or how did you
i don't think it's a lot easier now it
is it's there's a couple
there's a few things that really just
are uncomfortable enough i've the thing
i like
the thing i dislike the most the the
only thing i really dislike in
connection with my job
is if i have to fire somebody i mean
that does not get easy for
that easier for me as life has gone
wrong and saying no is not
like firing people but it's got a little
bit of the same aspect to it
it's not easy to say no particularly to
a friend
uh but i will have every day three or
four or five requests to do something
and i
i can't do them all you know and uh
but i'm not promising it gets easier but
but just keep doing it right otherwise
other people will be running your life
first of all focus on it right i mean i
think like you basically get what you
spend your time doing right i mean i
want the company to build
three products this year and we're going
to work on a few others because people
are interested in them
but those are the three things that i'm
spending my product time on right um
you get what you put into it um if you
spend
a third of your time trying to make the
people around you better
through getting better people mentoring
getting them to be better getting
the best people in your organization
you're known to more impactful roles and
i think over time that just accrues and
you get a better organization
do you think there's a proven formula
that if
a brand rookie guy he's got a lot of
ambitious gone out of this but not a lot
of knowledge on how to
do you think if he follows a formula
he's guaranteed to make it as an
entrepreneur no no no
okay so you don't believe there's a
guarantee to make it no because who
knows who you're going to be competing
with so if you put two two people both
following the same formula both in the
same industry
right which one wins you know maybe they
both can win and both be successful but
you know so i don't i don't think
there's a default default template for
success
but i think there's things that you can
do to put yourself in the best position
to succeed
you know so i talk about stuff in the
book you know i talk about the one thing
in business you can control is effort
you know um going out there and sales
curing all
you know so i i think you know and i
agree with your point that
there are things that if you do them you
put yourself in the best position to
succeed
but you know if you just walk into a
buzz you know
a buzz saw and somebody else is doing a
little bit better you know what happens
you know you're talking
you know alluding to it earlier about
entrepreneurs being born or built
you know and i think they're i knew i
was wired to be excited about business
how or why i don't know but you know and
there's certain guys that have the
genetics to jump out of the gym
right certain guys you know that you
know when they golf they have the muscle
memory and and the discipline
you know dirk um the whiskey may not be
the most talented guy in the nba
but his discipline and his focus to do
what's necessary to be successful
he's willing to do and combine it with
being seven feet tall and being skilled
you know it makes him an amazing
basketball player
so it's understanding what your skill
set is
finding the right place to use those
skills and then
going for it you know will that make you
250 grand it depends if you pick the
right industry
but whatever industry you pick if you
outwork everybody
if you try to be a little smarter than
everybody if you try to be a better
sales person than everybody
if you try to be better prepared than
everybody you've got your best chance
because
if you don't do it and somebody else
does
you know i have the same work like
someone's trying to take it all away
from you you know working i actually
work like someone's spending 24 hours
working 24 hours to take it all away
from you and that's kind of the way i
look at it
a lot of times my issue is people are
not setting
goals that will be something that
somebody who becomes rich or could do
anything you got to be excited about
working on that for 10 years
so you got to have a big enough goal
that you know you attract the best
people and you retain them
and you keep them focused and in my
experience you don't go wrong you know
maybe you don't hit it
next year or maybe you fail entirely and
you
discover something more exciting to work
on with the same set of people
i think that i learned that there are
only five things that
you need to do to be successful if you
do these five ways
five things you will be successful and
the first
is um to be clear on what your goals are
you have to know what you're going after
um you can't have everything in the
world
but you could have almost anything you
want
but you can't have everything you want
if you go after
your goals and they're clear you have to
know your goals
and along the way number two is you have
to identify and not tolerate your
problems a lot of people
tolerate problems and then you have to
diagnose those problems to get at the
root cause of those problems
and often the root cause is you maybe
you have weaknesses maybe you make
mistakes and with that or maybe somebody
else is making
mistakes we all have strengths and
weaknesses
and the power of being able to know our
strengths and weaknesses and know how to
deal with them is enormous
and only when you know what your
problems are and you diagnose that
specifically can you create a design
to get around those problems and that
design very specific design
you go get around the problems and then
you have to
if you have a design you have to be
reliable in doing that
and everybody is
bad at some of these steps and the key
is to work with other people who are
good where you're weak
the thing that i do at my company that
is very unusual
is that we are completely unreasonable
without reason without we don't use
yes i'm logical okay yes i'm a sane
person
but when it comes to achieving a target
we
we do it with like we abandon reason
and logic we don't talk about yeah but
we never start
yeah but or no we can't or we couldn't
because
or it didn't happen because any any time
you're talking anytime you're making
sense of why something didn't work we
don't have the budget
we can't do that because yeah but we're
different
you are being reasonable the great
things that have happened on this planet
and continue to happen are because
people are unreasonable
they literally abandon reason and logic
they defy the universe now if you look
around if you're a logical person if
you're a person who has to make sense of
it beforehand
then spend some time looking around the
universe look at nature look at all the
things that are done
every day that literally defy gravity
defy possibility defy physics
it's all over the place if you need to
be reasonable
now in my case i don't need to be
reasonable because there's enough
cases of super successful people doing
things that are amazing whether it was a
manufacturing a new product
or whether it was steve jobs coming back
to apple and turning that company around
every day every look at amazon look what
amazon has done
okay now you look at it you're like dude
that's a no-brainer
make every make all products available
online
now it's a no-brainer now it's like it's
so logical look at velcro
velcro was like god i i should have
thought of that
see but beforehand it was completely out
of
reason that you could stick things
together
uh because they scratch one another you
understand what i'm saying so look this
is what i want you to try
try this in your life it's going to be
very difficult it's one of the most
difficult things i do is being
unreasonable because all the people i'm
surrounded by
are trying to make sense of why they
can't do something
quit making sense of why you can't do
something and become unreasonable
until you do do something i have an
appointment right now
and i shouldn't have done this video
because i'm
i have an appointment now i have to rush
off to the appointment you see reason
would say
you don't have time and what i do is i
practice every day
being unreasonable little exercises
i'm going to be unreasonable i'm going
to shoot this right now
i'm going to get it done and then i'm
going to get my hair cut
see what i'm saying be unreasonable you
don't have the budget good go find the
money
you don't know how to use do this good
then do it anyway
right be unreasonable you the real
estate's not for sale
keep trying to drop these shades the
real estate's not for uh
not for sale the real estate's not for
sale
so what make an offer you understand i
just bought a 80 million
deal a trophy property trophy property
one of the major cities in the united
states
off market not for sale not interested
in selling
and we just closed the deal why because
i was completely unreasonable
until we got the deal be unreasonable
your mommy didn't teach you how your
daddy didn't teach you how
in fact your kid your parents your
teachers
society keeps telling you be reasonable
don't do it what would you say is the
best advice that you could give other
people from what you learned about
making their first million bucks
so say somebody's making six figures
scaling up and that's just do the math
you know what's what's first of all do
you want to make a million
or do you want to keep a million
they're completely they're like 60
difference between those two questions
right so specificity and the goal you
want to make
everybody's everybody watching is going
to make a million dollars i mean if you
live
25 years you're going to make a million
dollars 25 times 40 000 bucks
bang you made a million dollars if
that's your goal so
that this is what i talked about in the
10x rule the goals people are setting
are incorrect and that's why people give
up on their goals
because i know so many guys that hit a
million dollars
like i've had so many people come to me
and say i hit a million
and i lost the juice yeah it got
comfortable almost yeah a lot of guys in
network marketing tell me this
like i was in network marketing i became
a million dollar producer just
lost it because the goal was wrong the
goal was wrong first of all it wasn't
your goal
anybody's got a million dollar target
it's not your goal you adopted this goal
this idea from somebody else
because the number any number that ends
in zero is a lazy number
the chance is a number ending in zero is
almost mathematical what a great point
what a great point so it's a lazy
concept
you just adopted somebody else's idea i
want to be a millionaire
would do you have even done the math do
the math on a million dollars
it's no money this is why people they
they like god
hate grant because your target was a
million
you're struggling making 200. you think
a million is impossible you don't want
me to tell you the truth and the truth
is it is no money
as soon as you get it i read the book
the millionaire next door almost
everybody read that book back in the
90s it was the best book for me
because it taught me i don't want to be
a millionaire
it lifted the lid i'm like i don't want
to be the guy buying a ford truck
i don't want a ford truck man right
i got to buy a ford truck a used ford
truck f-150
so one day i could be a millionaire yeah
and i can't go get coffee i need to
bring a brown pack to my office every
day
not drink coffee at the shop in order to
be a millionaire well the reason i knew
that was not good for me was because my
dad died at 52 with a little bit of
money
and i'm like i don't want to die with
money when i'm old
i want to have enough money and that
that un did everything for me i want
financial freedom i don't want to hit a
quota
you know and i think everybody's
struggling for the quota they're
struggling for the bills they set their
financial plan based on
what their spending is or what their
apartment costs or what the mortgage is
rather or what their kids need rather
than i want freedom
i don't want financial literacy i want
financial freedom
you know so i hear people say oh we need
to teach financial literacy no you need
to teach financial freedom the
possibility of it what would i need
how much you know this whole cash flow
thing that i talk about all the time
cash flow is the holy grail of finance
that's why his business works that's why
he's able to enjoy the lifestyle he has
he has
financial freedom not a money number
five grand is a doable deal how do i do
it it's 412
dollars a month okay i got to go steal
the money i can steal 5000. you could
steal five grand for me and i wouldn't
even know it's going to be like
if you could add 5 000 to that and earn
20 it'd be worth a million 125
if you can do this at 10 it'll be worth
320. some of you small thinkers out
there be like dude i'll take the 320.
how do i get 10 and how do i get 20. you
guys have figured this out you're like
if the play is big enough dude i'll
figure that out everybody agree
see what i just i shifted your mind by
giving you a target
i don't go to target i get targets and i
keep targets and i refresh the target
and the target is i want to be a
millionaire but over the period of time
i got 20 years by the way
what would pay me 20 a year over 20
years
and that is when your boy gc
got rich i didn't get rich speaking
i didn't get rich selling books i got
rich shopping real estate
30 years old shopping every weekend dude
every weekend all i did between 25 and
30 years old was make money make money
make money and push it aside push it
aside push it aside
even when in the first years when i was
not watch this
even when i was not 25 years old
five grand boom next year five grand
boom next year five grand boom
guess what next year oh by the way this
money's sitting dead in the bank
it's not not only anything it's it's in
a it's in a holy
account holy means okay i'm gonna put a
hole in your face
if you touch my money nobody could get
this money this is a
like sacred account okay you with me 28
oh wow man i
could add a little bit maybe there's
more money 29
what am i doing right here okay one two
three four boom i got 25 000
sitting in an account it wasn't a
million dollars and i'm five years into
the plan
but when i was ready to start investing
money
i started doing my homework 30 years old
homework shopping properties 31
homework shopping properties 32. i'm not
buying cars
you guys are buying cars flying on jet
charters showing off going on vacations
all i'm doing is stacking paper
guess what happens i have five years of
putting five grand away
next thing you know i had twenty five
thousand dollars to add to my twenty
five thousand dollars
next year i'm making more money i got
twenty 25 000 you see what i'm doing i'm
stacking dough
and looking for 20
i know there's a 20 play out there some
of this money was sitting in the bank
this is years and years ago where the
bank would pay me six or seven or eight
it didn't matter that's not the target
the target is to get to one million
remember this
and let's open up the calls okay your
job is to find a vehicle that can pay
you 20
a year might be a business might be the
business you're in it might be to buy
advertising for the business or brand
you're in
for me it was this i'm gonna buy real
estate
that over long periods of time i will
earn
cash flow okay that's how the real
estate works
i put 25 000 in a deal
that deal is probably going to pay me 10
a year
you said yeah but grant you said what'd
you say grant would you say
20 grand that's what you said yeah i
know what i said
this ain't eddie okay now how much do i
have
i could reinvest that money back in the
deal the next year i have 27
[Music]
500. i earned 10
on that that's 27.50 or something like
that
i reinvest that now i got 30 000 in the
deal
okay but what you don't know is the rent
on this property
as i own it over 20 years 2038 will
dispose of this thing
the rent is going up as i'm adding money
the rent's going up
and maybe this goes from 10 a year
by the time i sell i want to be at 20
okay my average deal has paid me over 30
a year so when you start taking money
and start compounding it like that
for long periods of time the trick is
long periods of time
i think the reason why people drop their
financial goals
is because the goals aren't big enough
the the the
you know if you make another 20 pounds
or another 200 pounds or another 2 000
pounds it doesn't change your life
the goals are too small to start with
yeah but if you go from a million
to 100 million all of a sudden
everything changes
if you go from 100 million to a billion
yeah it changes again dude
it's like you go from a billion to a 10
billion dollar company
yeah you're like okay wait a minute now
now this is getting really serious
if you're a money motivated person yeah
and i know a lot of people aren't
right a lot of people just they've just
given up on it
but why did they give up on it because
well they've given up on it so it
doesn't even matter because
this entire conversation is going to
agitate them so they're like
i don't want to they probably already
tuned out they tuned out already i mean
i i didn't even get them in time
i should have told them that they were
going to tune out as soon as i started
talking about this
but uh and then we could have kept them
yeah um
but if you haven't given up on the money
thing
then you you know you need to unders you
just need to do some math
and you need to understand there's most
of the people that you're listening to
on social media
have given up on the money game yeah i
know guys that have five million dollars
they have given up
now the trip i just we're on our 31st
day if you got five million dollars in a
bank account you cannot do the trip i
just did
yeah okay you can't do the trip you you
don't have enough money to do the trip
man
this is what the guy with five million
dollars he made five million
and quit yeah dude he was just getting
rolling
he's like i don't need anymore or his
wife said we don't need anymore we're
good let's just enjoy life okay if you
can enjoy life at fit five million
dollars yeah i'll guarantee you at 50
you're going to have a hell of an
experience and you bank 500 million
and you're going to be like no now it's
getting real interesting not just for
yourself either
because if you if you got five million
dollars you can't only take so many
people with you that's right
i'm dragging people from all over the
all over the world with me man
that they're having experiences my
daughters are having experiences the
nanny
the nanny who's doing the homeschooling
she's like oh my god this is the best 30
days of my life
so when you get big enough man when you
get big enough
you can feed other families between six
and nine i'm gonna set up my first three
things to do that morning
i'm probably going to work out in my
case because i'm a father i'm going to
spend time with my kids
then i'm going to come back i'm going to
take a shower i'm going to get ready
have some breakfast
and be ready for a 9 a.m meeting nine to
noon
between nine and noon maybe i have phone
calls maybe i'm working on a project
maybe i'm shooting a video
i'll basically have those notes again
every line
every line on this page should be
filled up noon i'm gonna take a quick
lunch maybe 10 or 15 minutes have a bite
to eat
or i'm gonna spend a longer lunch but
it'll always be with a client
three to six six to nine i'm cranking
down
i'm turning it off i'm going to sleep if
you over
commit and under deliver if you can't
get to everything that's better
than having blank space on this calendar
now the right side is why i built the
10x planner
as a journal schedule planner
daytime or day runner call it what you
want your goals
these four or five lines right here are
going to be the most important way to
start your day because this is your
purpose
this is why you're living your life this
is the reason you're getting up
and going into work each day underneath
this you're going to see quote of the
day
what is your quote today this is a very
creative two lines
that's going to cause you to think about
what you stand for that day
these are your targets things you want
to accomplish this day calls you want to
make appointments you want to have
deals you want to close people you need
to see somebody you got to get in front
of
this is your exact target something
measurable then what do we have
successes so so important don't wait
till the end of the week or the end of
the month to write down your successes
what did you do today you went to the
dentist and had your teeth cleaned
boom that's a success for me that's a
major success
because i hate freaking dentists and by
the way make sure when you put your
successes down here
tweet me every once in a while and i'll
make sure i either retweet you or i'll
follow you
or i'll get you more followers last
thing write your goals down again you
wrote them down this morning you wrote
them down at night i can't tell you how
valuable this is okay
you write your goals down once a year
i'm gonna write mine down 700
times a year who wins this game a guy
smarter than me
taller than me better looking than me
better connected than me
writes his goals down once or twice a
year and i write mine down
700 times a year
who wins it won't be taller it won't be
richer
it won't be better looking it'll be the
guy that writes his goals down
twice a day every day this used to be a
goal of mine
to make one million dollars a year that
was my goal when i was 35 years old one
day
i said to myself one day i said self
little g-dog little g-dog
one day young man i wrote this over and
over and over again i talked to myself
in the mirror i'd sit on the toilet and
say one day
one day i'm gonna i'm gonna make a
million dollars
one day one day and people used to tell
me that's crazy dude
like why do you think so big this is
when people were telling me not to
they're like why do you need to do all
that why do you just be happy
just be a good person okay be happy that
you live in america be happy that you
have meals and be happy you've got good
health and
all the things that the people around
you that quit on money
that quit on financial freedom that quit
on possibility
they quit on their potential all the
things those people will tell you
to try to convince you to quit
when in reality what they're really
trying to do is make sense of why they
quit
note to self okay last month i
distributed
1.2 million dollars to other people
okay it's not money i made it's money i
sent out
so it just goes to show you how small i
was thinking when i was 35 years old now
i've got some special bonus clips that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week also if you've already
got your billionaire mindset companion
pdf calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free in the first line of
the description below and if you're
enjoying this billionaire mindset series
give me a hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
most people never hit their goals
because they don't structure their life
towards actually accomplishing those
goals
you can say that you want something you
can say that this is your ambition and
your goal
but unless it's in your calendar unless
you start actually working towards it
you're never going to accomplish it
dreams stay dreams because there is no
momentum
let's talk about how to get it one of
the common questions i get asked when
i'm doing my live stream when i'm doing
my
my interviews when i'm doing my my tour
my stops
people almost always will ask me how
many hours sleep do you get when you go
to bed when you get up how much do you
sleep every night
right now i'm sleeping nine hours a day
i sleep nine hours
i did a sleep study i was sleeping
around eight
and getting and was still tired when i
woke up and so i went and did an
overnight sleep study and he told me
i'm looking for the hack i'm like hey
you're you're deficient in magnesium
so just take these and you can sleep
seven and be normal
he said no nothing wrong with you you
just need to sleep nine hours a night
that's healthy for you like what that's
healthy are you kidding me what are you
talking about nobody sleeps nine hours a
night he's like yeah
between six and ten is actually that's
the normal range
the whole eight hours a night is a myth
so
i felt bad and i'm still trying to hack
it so i sleep nine hours a night i don't
wake up to an alarm
and people assume that i am i'm only
sleeping
three four or five hours a night because
of how productive i am during the day
this is it right you could sleep 12
hours a night
and crush it in the other 12 hours most
people default to thinking they need to
wake up an hour really say well if i
wake up at
5 00 a.m or at 4 00 a.m i'm going to be
more productive
if you are not productive for 16 hours a
day
then adding an extra hour to that it's
not going to make you that much more
productive
the problem isn't what time you wake up
the problem is what you're doing with
the hours that you're awake
and so as much as possible what i try to
do is make every second intentional
i'm not always able to achieve that
especially not every second but
but i try to make everything intentional
i try to make every where i'm spending
time is intentional i'm in the present
i'm not thinking about something else
i'm here with you guys making this video
right now
all i think about is this video that i'm
making for you right now
where's nina right now i don't know
where's my cell phone
well it's right here because i can see
it but where are my keys i don't know
where my dogs i don't know what am i
doing after this i have no idea
i'm focused and i'm with you right now
most people live in the past most people
are thinking about what could have been
most people are regretting the decisions
that they made
and they're procrastinating because
they're afraid of doing things because
they don't want to do things
all things that prevent you from
actually doing
that's the biggest problem you're a
genius
you're the best in the world at
something you can go off and make
amazing things the problem is your time
is not being used efficiently
it's not being used effectively either
you haven't structured your life
to help you accomplish your goals look
at your big goals look at your big goals
like what's the next big goal that you
have for yourself
you may not have one if that's if you
don't have one then you got to figure
out
what your purpose is because that's the
greatest thing of all time right get the
book built the serve you'll figure it
out
you'll be you'll be ignited but your
next big goal
now look at your calendar are you
aligning
what's in your calendar your daily
habits towards you accomplishing your
goals and for most people
it's no or you're you have it listed but
you're not doing it
because you look at it and you get
afraid and you procrastinate on it
so trying to cut that down to almost
zero even before making these videos
before making espresso videos i have
a couple minutes of procrastination um i
go and make sure i get my water
i go and maybe have a keto bar just
pacing around a little bit
because i'm nervous about making the
videos because i want them to be the
best videos that i've ever made
it's always my intention but too many
people live in
hours or days or months of
procrastination
instead of doing it you get the results
by doing it's the only way
you will never get the results by just
thinking about it you can be motivated
amazing you have the mindset awesome
that's half the equation the other half
is doing you have to actually just go
out there and do
you need to structure your life to allow
you to accomplish your goals
i'm going to leave you three step
process that will help step number one
is start with the mission and work
backwards
so the mission is lifetime the mission
is lifetime not not
what specifically you're going to be
doing but your purpose comes in your
pain we've talked about
that a lot on this channel i love
helping entrepreneurs because i
struggled so much as an entrepreneur
whoever you used to be where you
struggled and felt the most worthless
you will love helping those people for
the rest of your life that will never
get old
how you do it will change a lot right
now i'm doing it through youtube videos
i'm doing it through books i'm doing it
through my tours
all of that but but it's going to change
in 10 years it'll be different maybe
youtube's not around maybe people don't
have paper books anymore
you know there's going to be lots of
changes that come but that
mission that purpose will never change
it will never change
and when you figure out what it is for
you it will never change as well so
start with your mission and then you
start working backwards
step number two is understand that your
success is habits your success is habits
what you do on a regular basis is what
you're going to accomplish
you can eat a chocolate bar and be on a
diet and not get fat but if you eat a
chocolate bar every day you're going to
get fat you're not on a diet anymore
similarly if you eat salad once a week
it's not enough right
you are what you consistently do your
success comes from doing habits
and entrepreneurs are typically great
starters but not great at being
consistent and that's the problem
working your face off for for 48 hours
stretch isn't gonna do anything for you
it's every single day working even if
it's only an hour a day
that dream that you have that business
that you wanted to start that business
that you want to take to the next level
it could be there it could have been
there already it could have been there
already the problem is
you've been sitting on that idea for
three months six months four years
without doing enough on it little tiny
starts it's not enough
every day i'm talking every single day
making progress towards you actually
accomplishing that thing
you want that life you have to do it
every day and step number three is no
10-year goals
now what was interesting in this video
is jordan first talks about having
a three-year goal for yourself and then
he said for himself he can't plan for
more than six months because his life is
too
chaotic and too much stuff going on i
think that's actually the sign of a
healthy life like
there's no way you know where you're
gonna be in three years there's no way
you're gonna know
where you're gonna be in 10 years that's
crazy but three years is crazy too
there's no way i'm going i'm about to
leave on my tour
from january to april 2020 and
i'm gonna come back a different person
in april i'm gonna be a different person
than when i left when i'm about to leave
coming up now right so i don't know what
i'm gonna be doing after that
i have no idea i mean it's still going
to be within the confines of my mission
right i'm still going to be doing work
to help entrepreneurs so maybe i come
back and say i don't want to do youtube
anymore that's it i'm done
enjoy these last videos and i'm going to
move on and do something else
right so i don't think you can have an
accurate through your plan don't even
try
don't like this people get stressed out
about having the perfect three-year plan
there's no way like if you hate your
three-year plan you're thinking small
the idea like think of who you were
three years ago right let alone five
years ago or ten years ago
just take three years ago who you were
three years ago
could you accurately predict where you
are right now
there's no way not if you're growing
like jordan said
he starts off saying three year plan and
then goes down and said well i can't
only do
only six months i think that should be
normal like i think six months
should be the very end six months should
be the very upper limit
if you're growing if you're learning if
you're investing into yourself
but if you are different person than you
were three years ago what makes you
think with any degree of confidence
that you're going to be able to predict
your life three years out there's no way
you can't so don't worry about it don't
stress about it don't don't sit there
and have this plan for the next three
years
you're not gonna hit that plan that's
not your goal
your goal is to move closer to your
mission and you have to be flexible
enough to take the opportunities as they
come
you need to be people's chief goal
officer if you want to move them
into action if you want them to win you
have to speak to them in their language
and the things that they care about
the worst advice you could give somebody
is what you would do
if you treat everybody who works with
you and for you
like the way you would be treated you're
gonna lose forever you're never gonna
build the organization you want
because people have different goals and
it's your job to understand what they
are
so i'm doing this tour right now 90 days
23 cities
i often get asked by people hey evan
what book should i read
what video do you recommend from your
channel for an entrepreneur
i've done six thousand videos the worst
advice i could give is to give a generic
answer
the worst advice i could give is to one
that i would watch like here's a video
that i love the most
for me to give a good answer to you i
need to know your problem i need to be
your chief goal officer
i need to understand what you're
struggling with i could give you the
greatest book recommendation of all time
but if it's not the thing that you care
about right now it's not going to serve
you
and so before you give advice before you
try to help somebody else out
be their chief goal officer there's two
ways to do it
understand their who and understand
their why their who is their most
important one-word core value
and their why is their purpose and their
purpose comes from their pain so look at
the who i'll use an example with alex
who who runs toronto dance salsa for me
his who is belong his one word is belong
he wants to create a place where people
feel like they belong it's the one word
for him it's a one word for tds i know
that's what he really cares about
for me belonging doesn't really matter
if i don't feel like
i belong in a room i'm not bothered by
it i don't care what other people think
of me it's
it's so low down on my list of
priorities and values of what i
personally care about but for him it's
number one
he wants to make people feel like they
belong that's his one word most
important core value that's his who
so i understand a little bit more about
him i understand how to push him the
next is your why your purpose comes from
your pain
for him he struggled so much in in
making friends and feeling accepted
he had super sweaty hands and when he
held the girl's hand he would
slide out because he sweat so much and
it tied into him never feeling like he
belonged and so
this is now his purpose for life is to
help other people feel like they belong
that there's a space
for them to come to and feel like they
belong his favorite movie of all time
is hercules the disney movie the cartoon
where in that song they said something
about a place where you belong
and when he hears that song he cries
great this is
alex right i might play that song for
myself and
that's a good song i mean play that song
for somebody else and they hate that
song
screw hercules amazing everybody's
different
you need to be their chief goal officer
so if i'm talking to alex and trying to
motivate and push him and have him build
an amazing company that he's proud of
i'm going to use words like belong i'm
going to use movie references like
hercules
i'm going to talk about creating a place
where people can come together and feel
like they're finally accepted
because that's at the core of what he's
all about that's me being his chief goal
officer
and so you need to do that for everybody
on your team you need to do that for
every customer
that you work with stop treating
everybody the same way
there's the classic rule of do unto
others as you would have them do unto
you and that's great and that's treating
people with compassion and care and
kindness
but everybody's motivated by different
things and if you can
only treat people one way the way that
you would like to be treated you're
going to only have success with a very
narrow band of people
a very narrow band of customers a very
near band of employees
a very narrow brand of partners you're
going to stay in this tiny little lane
your entire life and never build a huge
company but if you can learn to be
somebody's chief goal officer
if you can learn to understand what
drives them moves them pushes them what
they're
who is what their why is why they're
here what they're trying to accomplish
you start building an eight-lane super
highway you can build a company that can
take over the world
we give up too easily on our goals
because we've proven to ourselves that
we can't follow through on our goals
every time you set a goal and you don't
follow through you're creating the
pattern in your head
the mindset the identity that i'm the
kind of person
who doesn't follow through so what
happens the next time you set a goal
well your your brain will kick in to say
you're not going to do that
how many times have you set a goal for
yourself it might be some big giant goal
right like i'm going to crush this year
and i'm going to be here by the end of
the year awesome might be some big goal
but chances are even the little ones
even the little goals like i'm gonna
work out today or i'm gonna
eat well today or i'm gonna make that
call today how many times have you set
even a little goal for yourself and then
not follow through
you didn't do it you're not allowed to
do that anymore
you have to be very intentional about
the goals you set for yourself and then
once you set them you have to follow
through
because what's happening is you don't
believe you anymore
the next time you come up with another
goal you say i'm going to create this
thing
i'm going to get this thing done you
might believe it in the half second that
you decided you're going to do it
i know what happens your brain is going
to take over and say
you're not going to do that thing are
you crazy
what makes you think you're going to do
that you didn't do these other 100
things you said you were going to do
either
your goals don't count until they're
hard and it starts
with as soon as you set a goal you
follow through
and expect it to be difficult if it's
easy it's a gift
expect it to be difficult and show
yourself that you do difficult things
most people either have no idea who they
are and what they want
or they do but they don't have the
courage and confidence to chase it down
if you don't know who you are and what
you want then that needs to be your
immediate priority that's the single
most important exercise that you can do
right now if you know what you want but
you're not chasing after it
having more confidence in who you are
will give you the courage to chase it
down
either way i'm gonna give you the
answers in this video so when i first
started making videos
i sucked you can go back you can watch
the first one it was april
2009 over 10 years ago i sucked i was
nervous i was shy i was trying to
memorize
lines i was sitting down i was in a suit
i was sweating
i sucked it was brutal and
making videos isn't a logical
choice for someone like me i was
introverted i still am
i was afraid of being in front of the
camera i'm looking into the lens and
the red light went on and i went blank i
was trying to memorize my lines just on
paper if you saw me and you said what i
was good at
and then put me in in a situation where
i'm making videos said don't do that
that's not for you
here's the thing i liked it i wasn't
good at it
but i liked it and when you like
something
with enough effort enough practice most
things
you can be great at it now i'm still on
my journey
i still have a long way to go there's
still people i look up to guys like gary
who are crushing it and say i still have
my journey to get better on but i'm a
lot better than i was when i started
and now i'm off doing keynote speeches
and i'm getting flown out and getting
paid to speak in front of audiences and
i'm growing a channel with
two million subscribers and then these
sub channels on top of them it's crazy
because i was doing a thing that on
paper i wasn't supposed to be good at
but i just loved it and that's where the
self-awareness piece comes in
because you will get an idea to go off
and try something but you'll judge the
idea and you'll say i can't do this
because i don't have
x and y and z and i'm not good enough
and tall enough and smart enough
or whatever enough right i'm not enough
and then you play small for life and you
have uncertainty and you're walking on
quicksand and you end up being pulled
into making somebody else's dreams come
true instead of you watching chasing
your own version
of your life down because you're
thinking about all the reasons
why you're not gonna win instead of the
eight why you will
so take it from me a guy who's
introverted afraid of the camera
shy doesn't like talking to people
if i can get here so can you on your
dreams
as time has gone on i've become less and
less a fan
of goal setting and i love the idea
quarterly goals
over annual goals over decade-long goals
because the timeline is shorter and why
i'm less a fan of goal setting is
because
the more you're actually growing the
less
likely you're actually able to predict
where you're going to be
so i really hate 10-year goals
5-year goals 10-year goals if you think
about where you were five years ago
think about who you were five years ago
five years ago look at the calendar five
years ago from today
in the past who are you you think that
person
could predict where you would be 10
years ago
10 years ago i just started my youtube
channel
i had a couple videos up 10 years ago i
said i'd never want to write a book
10 years ago i wouldn't imagine that i
i'd be here every year
making videos for a youtube channel with
300 million views
in puerto rico because brendan burchard
invited me to his mastermind group
to speak on stage in front of all these
successful entrepreneurs
i wouldn't have predicted that like with
with zero accuracy
and same thing for you 10 years ago you
had no idea that you'd be here not if
you're growing
and this is the big caveat not if you're
growing like if you can predict
with accuracy where you're going to be
in 10 years
you can hit it but it's just way small
compared to what you could have done
and it means that you haven't grown in
the past decade
and so that's my main beef against goals
and and having shorter goals having new
miracles can be great
can be great like i want to get 10
million subscribers on my main youtube
channel
that's a good goal but if i set that as
my 10-year goal and that's the only
thing i'm gonna do
then it's wrong because probably in
three years i should jump off and go do
something else
right i've been fortunate that i've been
doing youtube for 10 years i i still
love it it's still amazing but
chances are your 10 year plans you
should jump off in year two and go do
something else because that thing is
actually better for you
because you've grown as a person so at
least that's great
the advice that instead of annual goals
set it down to quarterly goals because
goals are still
helpful they're so good to kind of track
your progress to know that
this video did better than that video
that this customer brought in more money
than this customer that are you doing
enough actions to go and get the
business that you want
those are great but as a macro
thing that's leading your decisions i
think the longer you stretch it out
the worse it actually is most people
don't hit their big goals because they
don't believe that they can because
you've trained yourself that when you
set a goal
and when it gets hard you quit if you're
on a diet
and that food comes in and it smells oh
so good
you eat it you're training yourself that
you set
goals and don't follow through you set
goals and you don't follow through
you set an alarm to wake up at a certain
time and you hit the snooze button first
thing in the morning you set a goal
and you did not follow through and so
now when you set new goals
you've trained yourself you've
conditioned yourself that i'm the kind
of person
who doesn't follow through so instead of
do it anyway i'd switch it to
do it because i said i would sticking
with your goals
doing it when it's hard that's how you
build self-respect
self-esteem and self-confidence so let
me use myself as an example today
i am on a ketogenic and intermittent
fasting diet which means
i eat keto so it means i can't eat a lot
of different foods
got to stay healthy and i eat starting
at 2 p.m
and ending at 8 p.m so in that 6 hour
windows when i eat
and the other 18 hours i'm fasting that
makes it really tough
so today especially was difficult for
whatever reason
today was extremely difficult i wanted
to eat
so bad 10 o'clock starting from 10
o'clock like
i want to eat then my wife is
experimenting with this new keto bread
using almond flour and it smells so good
and then at 11 o'clock she's eating it
and she brings it into the office and
she's eating it
and i smell it like
oh my gosh that smells so good
it's 11 o'clock i still got three more
hours until i can eat but in that period
when it's difficult when i can't do it
when i set a goal for myself that i'm
not going to eat
until 2 o'clock what happens if i eat
early
it's just one day right just one bite
just a couple bites who cares
i lashed it till eleven o'clock
what happens when you eat early
you taught yourself that you don't
follow through i'd be reinforcing the
fact that i don't follow through
and then the next time i set a goal my
brain is gonna tell me yeah you're not
gonna actually do that
i might get amped up and pumped up in
the moment to say i can do that
but the next day i'll be telling myself
now i can't do that
you never hit your goals that's the
problem that's where most people live
because
until it's hard it doesn't count
because if you set a goal that's just
easy to hit that means your standards
are super low
it's not a real goal if your goal is to
to wake up
and breathe today okay great for some
people that might should be
a big challenge but for most people
that's an easy thing to do
if it's an easy goal then it's not
really a goal
if it's a hard goal then this will be
moments that will challenge you and
what you do in the moments that are
challenging to you
is what defines you either in a negative
light or positive one
i said i was not going to eat until two
o'clock so i had to wait
and then come two o'clock on the dot
i'm running out getting the bread
smelling it
oh my god i can still taste it right now
and and just sitting back in the chair
and and enjoying everything that was
that
almond bread goodness and my wife is
trying to have a conversation like
i just need five minutes just me and the
bread and
and it's not just enjoying the taste of
the bread
which was great and i was hungry but
it's enjoying the taste
of doing the goal it's doing it because
i
said i was going to do it and how great
that feels
we need to build our self-confidence up
and that comes by when you say you're
going to do something
guess what you do it and when it's hard
you do it because you said you were
going to do it
i'm going to give you a three-step
process to walk you through this that i
think will really help you stay
consistent on your goals
step number one tell yourself it doesn't
count until it's hard
i love setting goals when i'm feeling
optimistic and positive and bold and
motivated i think that's actually the
best
part to set goals that's the best time
to send goals when you're feeling
optimistic positive bold and powered
that's that's the best part of you and
then your brain spends 99 of the time
talking you down from your big ambitious
goals
so you set a goal for yourself great it
doesn't count
until it gets hard tell yourself
it doesn't count until it gets hard so
that when the difficulty comes you're
expecting it to come
if difficulty doesn't come your goal is
too easy this isn't being negative being
pessimistic
i'm the most optimistic person around
i know it's going to get hard if it's
not hard my goal was too low
if at some point it doesn't get
difficult my goal was too low
so difficulty is coming for me tell
yourself
that embrace it get ready for it because
when it happens like it did for me today
on my diet goal at 10 am when i'm
starving
i tell myself it doesn't count
unless it's hard step two tell yourself
it's the best this is the best you don't
want an easy life you don't want to have
a life with no challenges
challenges are how you grow you want to
be a hero you want to do great things
everything that you want out of life is
on the other side of doing difficult
things this is the best
this moment where you feel weak when you
feel like you want to crumple this is
the
best this moment right now for me when
i'm when i was starving
and i had to wait another four hours to
eat was it four hours
ten o'clock four hours to eat
that's the best this is my chance this
pain you're in right now this is your
chance
when it's difficult when it's hard when
you want to give up this is your chance
to show yourself and the world exactly
what you're made of this is the defining
moment right now
that you get to define for yourself what
it means to be
you because i know what it means to be
evan carmichael
and now it's your time to step up this
is the best
and then step three is celebrate
celebrate when you do something that's
difficult
even if you don't crush it you just did
it then you need to celebrate we don't
celebrate enough and i'm victim of this
i don't celebrate enough
i want to move on to the next thing but
where i do celebrate
is doing difficult things not so much
the winning
of some award right the youtube awards
and all that stuff
i don't need to celebrate that stuff but
i celebrated
hitting my two o'clock goal right i
didn't want to celebrate hitting a
million subscribers but i want to
celebrate
waiting until two o'clock to eat my food
what you pay attention to what you
celebrate matters
i want to celebrate the things that make
me feel good about myself
and you should too if you're doing
something difficult if you barely cross
the line but you did it when it was
difficult
that's not a small win that's not just
ah you barely made it that's the holy
cow
are you kidding me when it was difficult
when you wanted to quit when you went to
gave up you kept going
amazing pat yourself on the back
you got to celebrate that stuff now you
can celebrate it to yourself i
i keep it all internal i'm telling
myself i'm the best
you can celebrate it online with your
friends family whatever makes the most
sense for you but celebrate it
when you got through something hard and
you're part of your effort you deserve
to celebrate if you want to sign up for
the entire billionaire mindset series
for free and get the companion bonus pdf
calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there